ils existent elles vivent dans le sol
depuis des centaines de millions
d'années les agriculteurs s'y
intéressent de plus en plus et certains
experts croient que grâce à elle une
révolution verte est peut-être en cours
4 merci bonsoir à recenser les rend ce
soir nous parler d'un sujet encore assez
méconnue les mycorhizes de quoi
s'agit-il au juste va démystifions
d'abord le terme en mycorhizes ça vient
du grec micro pour champignons risa
racines des plantes ce qui se passe
c'est que sous la terre il ya une
association entre les champignons les
plantes aidés par les bactéries
en fait ils entretiennent une relation
qui mutuellement bénéfique a plein
d'égards j'aimerais regarder des images
avec vous céline manic 5 hl au lendemain
la construction du barrage c'était un
paysage lunaire un champ de roche
on a demandé un biologiste de faire
pousser une forêt et contre toute
attente il est arrivé ça démontre la
force de cette association la entre les
arbres et les champignons qui oui sont
plus efficaces que les plantes pour
aller chercher l'eau dans le sol mais
ils sont aussi capables les champignons
de littéralement mangé la roche aller
chercher les minéraux dans la roche pour
la transférer aux plantes que les arbres
les plantes sont incapables de faire
fort mais elles ont seulement pas la
capacité et en retour les plantes vont
transférer du sucre aux champignons
qu'elle obtienne de la photosynthèse
alors huaxi donnant donnant bon alors
quel genre d' influence s'est uni
choristes peuvent avoir sur
l'agriculture par exemple mais ce qu'on
se rend compte c'est que l'agriculture
moderne à leur fait des bonds prodigieux
oui mais on s'est toujours consacré
seulement sur la plante on lui donne de
l'engrais pour la nourrir on utilise des
pesticides et herbicides pour la
protéger alors et on voit que ça des
conséquences environnementales terrible
mais la plante elle est très bien
capable de se nourrir elle même grâce
aux bactéries grâce aux champignons elle
le fait depuis des millions d'années
alors lorsqu'on voit et à chaque fois
qu'on l'a bourque ont remué la terre on
brise ces raisons-là de champignon
souterrain alors lorsqu'on voit ce qu'il
ya des compagnies ne plus en plus il y
en a eu
né à rivière du loup dans le bas saint
laurent qui propose des semences
enrobées de mycorhizes dans le fond on
veut imiter ce que la nature fait depuis
déjà fort longtemps
il ya des agriculteurs qui commence à
s'en servir il sait quels sont les
résultats
mais les résultats on a vu notamment
dans l'ouest dans les cultures de
lentilles une hausse de rendement
pouvant aller jusqu'à 10% sipa fulgurant
ce qu'on voit c'est que ça pourrait
permettre de réduire l'utilisation de
pesticides d'engrais ça c'est des gens
très bonne nouvelle ça représente des
coûts énormes pour les producteurs mais
il ya encore beaucoup de recherches à
faire pour trouver le mariage parfait
entre la bonne plante le bon ben là
bonnes bactéries et les bons champignons
alors si fascinant mais ce n'est qu'un
début donc si je comprends oui et on
vous en parlera pendant toute l'heure de
la semaine verte en fin de semaine à ne
pas manquer mon collègue obertan ont
bien préparé ce pas on va regarder ça
merci beaucoup car son prix